if you want to hear my two fan theories
about the upcoming movie glass then
stick around to the end of this video I
just watched the trailer through glass
this has got to be my most anticipated
movie of all time this movie is good
this could be the greatest trilogy ever
so as you can imagine I've got a lot to
talk about here please do yourself a
favor make sure you've seen these movies
before you watch this video the trailer
opens by introducing us to dr. Ellie
staple a psychiatrist who specializes in
individuals who believe that they are
superheroes now and split there's a
psychiatrist named dr. Fletcher who
works with the Horde one of the many
personalities asked dr. Fletcher what
would happen to them if she were to pass
away and this is her response if ever
something would have happened to me I've
made arrangements with a colleague from
Baltimore to take over what if this
doctor staple is the colleague from
Baltimore the name of the asylum as seen
on this nametag later in the trailer is
Ravenhill Memorial Baltimore was the
home of Edgar Allen Poe who wrote the
famous poem The Raven and of course the
NFL team the Ravens reside there but
this movie does like almost all of
Shannon's films including splittin and
breakable take place in Philadelphia
next we see some shots from around the
asylum including this one from Kevin's
room you can tell because of the 24
tooth so at the beginning of the shot
the lights are off and all we can see
are these three panes of glass that
could come to represent the three main
characters not long after we are shown
those three characters all together in
the same room perhaps the most shocking
part though is that David Dunn is the
only one who's chained up the big
question is going to be what did he do
to become a criminal this could be a
situation similar to The Incredibles
where his acts of heroism also caused
damage because he does kind of just walk
him to people's houses uninvited later
in the trailer this appears to be his
arrest scene and then later on he seems
to be surrendering and the removal of
his raincoat is a symbol of him showing
weakness during his arrest because an
unbreakable water is essentially his
kryptonite there's also this woman who's
holding up stop signs possibly David's
wife or possibly dr. staple back to the
shot though I'm guessing that Elijah
simply doesn't need to be chained up
because he isn't a physical threat but
if they've now captured the hoard you'd
think that he would be chained up as
well pay attention to the order that
they're sitting in because in the next
shot there's some books propped up in
the comic book
store the Legion of regretable
supervillains is the book on the left
and the League of regrettable
superheroes is on the right and there's
something in the middle I can't tell
what book it is but it probably
represents the Horde there's also
something off to the side here if the
bad guys are teaming up in this movie
maybe David teams up with a new
character as well for the record I don't
consider Kevin to be a bad guy but out
of the 24 personalities that reside in
his body at least three of them are bad
and I think that's what Elijah is
referring to when he says that lying
about the bad guys teaming up this scene
is a very reminiscent of the comic book
store scene in unbreakable where Elijah
has the epiphany about David Dunn having
a weakness the character in the comic
that he's looking at has a resemblance
to the beast the 24th personality in
splits but with hair this panel of him
bending the bars is just like the Beast
bending the bars of the cage at the end
of splits and just to break down this
page these two are in some kind of
danger when the beast guy comes in and
grabs the bars he says what they've done
to us is unforgivable I've vowed to
protect everyone from something it's too
blurry to read at that point but then he
breaks through the bars and the villain
says time for me to get out of here and
the Beast goes after these yellow eyes
in the dark and his last quote is I
don't know how much longer I can keep
chasing it I think it's likely that
we'll see a scene similar to this in
glass perhaps the character in the comic
doesn't represent the beast but rather
David Dunn if that's the case maybe him
breaking out of the bars corresponds to
this and I don't know how much longer I
can keep chasing him refers to him
getting older before we move on from
this page of comics they cut the trailer
to make it look like Elijah price is the
one reading the comic but I don't think
those are his head's okay this shot
shows David Dunn in a diner slash Casino
and because I know people are gonna ask
no it's not the same diner from at the
end of split there is however a news
report on the screen showing something
going on in socket tower which I'm
guessing is supposed to be a building in
Osaka Japan
so I think mr. glass is up to his old
tricks again once he inevitably escapes
next shot David bumps into this guy
whose face we can't see at first after a
quick flash back of these chained up
cheerleaders we see about it's Kevin or
at least one of the personalities but
which one it could be Dennis who's
stated and split to have a thing for
watching young girls dance naked but it
could be Hedwig who's the owner of that
jacket and loves listening to music okay
okay fine roll it
[Music]
Hedwig would probably be the only one to
wear his headphones outside of its hood
like that but if that is Hedwig that
means that either
Hedwig is complicit like he was in the
kidnapping of the girls and splits or
David can see the actions of the entire
horde by bumping into Kevin's body by
the way the position that the girls are
chained up and almost looks to be a
callback to the way that the janitor
tied up those girls and unbreakable in
glass we'll get to see a bunch of new
personalities that had files in the
computer and split but who never
actually made an appearance in the light
such as Mary Reynolds someone who speaks
Spanish and apparently Logan Paul when
mr. glass is talking about his brittle
bone disease we see this x-ray from July
1999 now unbreakable came out in 2000
and had take place in 99 this could be
the very same x-ray from that fall down
the stairs at the subway however I don't
think that's the reason that he's still
in a wheelchair now because in
unbreakable the doctor tells him that
he'll be in a wheelchair for a couple of
months and then he'll be on crutches
after that split takes place 15 years
after unbreakable and I imagine glass
takes place shortly after split because
there's a brief shot in the trailer
where the Beast looks to still have any
gunshot wounds from split also mr.
glasses crutches do make an appearance
at the end of the trailer so maybe he
won't be wheelchair-bound for the
entirety of the third one like some
people there's a brief shot in the
trailer of a crowded room with almost no
context but if you pay attention to this
sign you'll notice that it's a train
station trains are significant in both
films in unbreakable it's David survival
of a train accident or I guess I should
say train wreck that first gets Elijah's
attention and he also searches for
criminals by bumping into them at the
train station in split the train yards
where Dennis goes to unleash the Beast
and it's also mentioned that the root of
his disorder has something to do with
his dad leaving on a train when he was
very young fan theory I'm gonna say that
his dad was on the same train that
derailed at the beginning of unbreakable
this is a very interesting shot at one
point in the trailer we see Casey from
split reaching out to the horror here we
see her leaving the asylum with Elijah
prices mom from unbreakable and David
Dunn's son Joseph Dunn who is all grown
up now could Joseph possibly be the
owner of the comic book shop whose face
is conveniently hidden and as a side
note this character whoever he is seems
to be making a symbolic choice between
heroes and villains that brings me to
fan theory number two roll the clip meet
the Beast
I hope for your sake that he likes you
that sounds like the bad guys
teaming up I think the Beast does end up
liking mr. glass for the same reason he
likes Casey in splits because he's
physically broken and in the eyes of the
beast that makes him pure unlike David
who is
and speaking of unbreakable after this
shot where two nurses are running away
from the asylum and David Dunn can be
seen in his raincoat in the background
the trailer ends with imagery of broken
glass
Christmas has come in late this year in
January I mean technically that's next
year but you get my point
if you are stoked for this movie if you
are ready to complete the unbreakable
trilogy let me know by leaving this
video and like and let me know your
theories about glass in the comments
they say this one has a surprise ending
and finally if you're interested in
seeing things you missed video is on
unbreakable split and glass make sure
you're subscribed to see these worlds
for new Horrors every week wring that
death panel for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive